educate on Romania got arrested and his
brother and his brother as well so if
you guys remember back in April there
were human trafficking charges such
against Andrew Tate for supposedly
holding captive uh two women one
Romanian one American woman uh they both
tell different sides the woman claims
that she was held there against her will
by the Tate brothers and she wasn't
allowed to leave and her her boyfriend
ended up calling the embassy which makes
you wonder like what is she doing out
there who knows we don't know okay but
she claims that she was held and she
contacted her boyfriend or somebody was
watching the live stream and that's how
they found out and they called
they called the police
the Tates say no this girl flew in
Tristan was the one that was talking to
her and essentially two conversations uh
she ended up flying out to Romania to
party and then they kept her she went
over there and based off the CCTV
footage that they have inside they
claimed that she was free to leave and
she can go at any time
Romania police released them after the
April 11 stuff and we don't care anymore
about this and fast forward to today
and they've charged him which means that
after investigation things have shifted
controversial influencer Andrew Tate and
his brother Tristan are arrested in
Romania as part of a human trafficking
probe news broke late Thursday evening
by bno news that the pair were arrested
on December 29th now this news comes
just hours after Tate made waves with
climate activist Greta thundberg going
back and forth on Twitter about carbon
dioxide emitting cars Tate who had
previously been kicked off social media
platforms for so-called misogyny and
hateful ideations had also made news
last month as long crime networks
sidebar reported he sued YouTuber Ethan
Klein after Klein called him a sex
trafficker now at the time Tate's
attorneys sent Klein a cease and desist
order some reports now say Romanian
officials used Tate's social media to
confirm he was in their country before
his arrest we're still learning new
details in this case and will continue
to bring you the latest developments as
they come in
here
you like
peace of mind
[Music]
um
now some people speculate that it's
because he's had his little spat with
Greta thundberg on Twitter and it's made
news coverage all over the world that
the Romanian people government sent the
police after other folks say it's
because the investigation hard to say uh
I would wager that I don't think the
Romanian police would go after him
because of a bunch of tweets about Greta
so likely but it's because of one of the
video they knew he was in Romania
because in one of the videos that he did
to address Greta that was a pizza box
there's me from Romania so they're like
oh this [ __ ] home but that's
what they're going to know anyways you
can't come in and out of Romania through
passports and through airports without
the if they want to find you in the EU
they're gonna find you and he wasn't
like he was hard to find he was in the
UK doing interviews he was all over
Europe doing stuff so like if they want
to find them they don't need to see a
pizza box to find him you get what I'm
trying to say I'm just reporting what
they say yeah yeah yeah well listen
right now information is sparse out
there I think some people who believe
he's a human trafficker and all these
things are going to drop result for joy
and they want to seem down and look at
the end of the day if these charges are
true then yeah throw the book at them I
don't care like somebody's holding
people hostage or holding people against
the will whatever the punishment is in
Romania you wanted to go there to get
away from the law in the UK whatever the
lies in Romania you got to live by that
right
however if it isn't true and this is
just some kind of smear campaign or some
other [ __ ] then that'll be very
disappointing because I think trying to
cancel someone for an influence that you
deem is extremely detrimental by using
the law I just we've seen that a few
times already and I just don't like them
I have nothing to say because I don't
have any information information on that
so I can't make any speculations I can't
make like oh this is what happened this
is because of this or that or whatever
that this is a proof of I don't know I
don't know guys what's your what's your
what's what's your an asthmatic do it
and as a matter of fact and as a matter
of fact Abba was like yeah we could
cover it and I said no we're not not now
I ain't got we ain't got [ __ ]
like the one the the wonderful
philosopher uh
Lil Wayne said you like a [ __ ] with no
ass I Ain't Got You
you'd have to speak on the validity of
the Chargers I think there's something
to be said though about the fact that
there is a concerted effort to get this
guy removed from every social media
platform that there is people who are
trying to curb this man's influence some
people say it's Justified because he's
dangerous other people know say it's
[ __ ] and I always said the
de-platforming wasn't going to have the
affected intended and I think even now
he's still very large in terms of his
social media presence I see him do
interviews and they hit millions and
millions and millions of views to this
day in fact his videos are still popular
on Tick Tock or in other places and
young men are still flocking to hear
about this too so I don't think the Deep
platforming campaign that went up
against him worked and so for the fans
of his who already love his work and
already seen him de-platform when these
charges are brought up what do you think
they're thinking right now this is a
this is a sham it's a [ __ ] sham but
the thing that happened like you said
let's get a tournament like that that's
a thing
foreign
against the dude uh uh personally
I hope
this is true
I hope this is true because if it's not
true
nobody's gonna believe nothing you say
oh my God if you went that route and
it's actually not true
you're shooting yourself in the whole
ass leg to do an investigation like this
and then charge somebody I would hope
they didn't I would I'm just hey I'm
just that's okay that's all I'm saying
just because of the I hope it's true
cause if it's not
you're [ __ ] up a whole bunch of
people true you're [ __ ] up victims
you're [ __ ] up the system you're
[ __ ] up you're [ __ ] up a whole
bunch of people if this [ __ ] is not true
you will not be able if that was your
point to cancel this dude you won't you
will not this this dude is gonna be a
super
[ __ ] he's still a superhero you
understand what I'm saying invited a
bunch of places and stuff like that if
this [ __ ] is not
my God no like Abba says good Lord true
you you [ __ ] that one up true
that's gonna be a big one I'm curious to
see how this is gonna unfold it's gonna
be huge there's an investigation for
these last like seven eight months and
then charged them so this is not like I
imagine there's probably some political
pressure involved in this case because
of how he makes Romania look in regards
to the greater EU but I'm just saying
this one this one looks a little bit and
the second thing charges it doesn't mean
he's guilty no but but they're not doing
that off of nothing no and if you are
that's [ __ ] up and second thing
if he gets scot-free
because you don't have enough
no but you know what would be [ __ ] up
what if they do charge him into some
kind of sham Court you know what that's
[ __ ] up he left the UK because the
courts and the laws were [ __ ] went
to Romania said the laws here are fired
they could be bothered whatever turns
out they can't they can't because
there's somebody with more money that
can [ __ ] you over that's [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up too so well regardless
of how you look at it it's gonna be big
I think so I think so we're just gonna
stand by and wait I guess there's
nothing much more I can do let us know
what you guys think you guys think top G
gonna make it